[Music]
tonya harding's troubles her second
chance almost ended on the first night
of Dancing with the Stars
Keltie night was there I couldn't
believe that you are up for elimination
the next couple who is in jeopardy is
Tania and Sasha serious moment I think
I've been in in a really long time
the couple who is safe is Tania and
Sasha
it's amazing we're going to the second
round
Tania moves on but can she take the
pressure
the competition is having an emotional
impact on the Olympian who broke down in
last night's rehearsal footage I want
people to see that I deserve to be here
and also when we talked to her during a
practice session with Sasha Farber like
no Sark Ryan Tania had some
oscar-winning support that's Allison
Janney who played Hardy's mom in I Tania
cheering her on
meanwhile a tie for first place between
NFL star Josh Norman and Olympian Adam
rip on the 28 year old skater says he
learned from the competition last night
well here's the thing there were a few
shirtless men or like opened lasered men
loved it how am I gonna outdo that I'll
find a way I always find a way okay and
finally after his cha-cha landed him in
last place a sweet surprise for 71
year-old Kareem abdul-jabbar look who
this is
Ichi arranged a viewing party in New
York with creams favorite childhood
teacher and we brought them together on
FaceTime hi John Susannah I cream you
did a great job that's my seventh and
eighth grade school teacher it's great
to see her she looks great she's 95
years old he did his best and he
inspired older people to live life to
the fullest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]